hello and welcome to med simplified
in our previous videos on acid reflux we
had an overwhelming response from you
guys
first things first thank you all for
being such an
awesome followers also most of you had a
lot of queries regarding acid reflux
so we are trying to come up with similar
content to answer most of those
questions
now it is a sage advice that prevention
is better than cure
also medications may seem the easier way
out on a short-term basis
just pop one pill and you're done but
doctors and researchers agree that
non-medication related changes
and life improvements are much
sustainable and more effective on a long
term
so keeping that in mind in this video we
will discuss a few things you can do
to manage acid reflux without
medications
i am dr umar malik from med simplified
and let's begin
number one eating sparingly and slowly
when the stomach is very full the
pressure inside increases
this leads to more food which tries to
push and reflux back into your esophagus
to prevent this you can practice a
method of eating known as grazing
eat small balanced meals eat frequently
and avoid eating large meals three times
a day
this will reduce the pressure on your
esophagus and helps to control the
reflux
number two avoid certain foods
people with acid reflux were once
instructed to eliminate
all but the blandest foods from their
diets but that's no longer
the case people with reflux can easily
manage symptoms by avoiding not all
but a very few common culprits these
include foods like
mint fatty foods spicy foods tomatoes
onions garlics coffee tea
chocolate and alcohol if you eat any of
those foods regularly
you might try eliminating them to see if
doing so controls your reflux
and then try adding them back one by one
for more food tips for people with acid
reflux and gastroesophageal reflux
disease
click the banner on the top to watch our
video on the topic
if you haven't already number three
don't drink carbonated beverages
the fizziness of carbonated beverages
comes from the gas that is pressurized
into them
when you drink these beverages gases are
released
which in turn makes you burp burping
sends the acid
back into your esophagus and worsens the
reflux
drink flat water instead of sparkling
water and cold rings
number four stay up after eating
when you're standing or even sitting
gravity helps to keep the acid
in the stomach when you lie down on a
full stomach
food pushes up into the esophagus and
eventually causes a reflux
for this make it a habit to finish
eating meals
3 hours before you go to bed i know it's
very irresistible
but to decrease your chances of reflux
you should avoid
naps after lunch avoid late suppers and
also avoid midnight snacks also it's
probably best to avoid vigorous exercise
for a couple of hours after eating an
after dinner stroll or casual walk is
fine
but a more sternous workout especially
if it involves bending over
can send acid back into your esophagus
number five sleep on an incline
another way to let gravity do its job is
by inclining your bed when you sleep
when you incline your bed gravity
prevents upward rise of food and liquid
into your esophagus
essentially preventing the reflux
ideally your head
should be six to eight inches higher
than your feet
you can achieve this by placing small
wooden blocks
under the upper pillars of your bed to
raise the height of the upper end of the
bed by six to eight inches
you can also try this by using a foam
wedge support for your upper body
just ensure you provide yourself uniform
support and don't obstruct your natural
sleep
number 6 lose weight the muscular
structure that supports the lower
esophageal sphincter
helps to keep it tight and closed when a
person is overweight
there is stress on this muscular
structure which leads to weakness of the
esophageal sphincter
this is the initiating point of reflux
problems
studies have concluded that obesity is
associated with statistically
significant increase in the risk of
reflux
gerd symptoms erosive esophagitis sore
throat
and esophageal cancer they also found
that this risk progressively increases
with increasing weight
doctors agree that it's better to eat
less exercise more and lose weight
rather than undergo surgery or taking
medications for acid reflux
number seven if you smoke quit
nicotine a key part of tobacco is
thought to relax the ring of muscles in
the lower esophagus that keeps
acid in the stomach whenever you smoke
that ring relaxes and acid trickles up
and causes that burning sensation
smoking also decreases the mucus your
body normally produces
mucus is important to prevent acid from
attacking the stomach and esophagus from
the inside
so when mucus decreases the reflux
symptoms increase
also most smokers have chest related
problems that make them cough more
and often cough increases pressure
inside the abdomen
this increased pressure increases reflux
every time you cough acid gets sent
upwards and the heartburn increases
nicotine gums and patches are safer bets
for
overall health they will help you
overcome your habit
and they are less likely to give you
heartburn one small study
found no increase in heartburn risk in
people
who used a nicotine patch i do not
need to emphasize how much smoking
destroys our body from inside
to know more about how smoking affects
your body watch our video by clicking
the banner above
so friends here we are with seven ways
to control reflux without medications
don't forget to like and share this
video drop a comment in the section
below on what topics you would like us
to make a video in the future
as always if you like our content and
want to support us subscribe to our
channel
become a member on youtube or support us
on patreon
thank you so much for watching and see
you in the next video